today is also a day of sadness because  it marks the one year anniversary of the  parkland tragedy of gun violence  one year ago America's heart was broken  by the horrific act of violence and  parkland Florida today we remember the  17 lives that were stolen from us then  I'm very pleased that last night a House  Judiciary Committee and the leadership  of Jerry Nadler and with the full  participation of our our members took a  strong step to end the epidemic of gun  violence and they advanced HR 8 the  bipartisan common-sense background check  legislation our committees are hard at  work I'm very proud of our freshmen I  think I've